we're here in Indonesia for this class
in underwater survival example what a
type of angler fish called a frog fish
you think you're looking at a yellowish
sea sponge and you are but if you look
very closely you'll see a frog fish
sitting there that's what a frog fish
does sits there so bigger fish get used
to it and leave it alone
example to the ghost pipefish these guys
have evolved to mimic something no
self-respecting predator would be caught
dead eating huh seagrass hence these
ghost pipefish are free to drift
wherever the tide takes them example 3
the leaf scorpionfish
a similar strategy to the ghost pipefish
the leaf scorpionfish has evolved itself
to look like a leaf on the sand an
example for the cockatoo wasp fish a
final example of this scheme not only
has the cockatoo wasp fish evolved to
look like a dead leaf it's learned to
rock back and forth like a leaf wood so
what's the takeaway from today's class
to stay alive down here
morphing into a plant shape might be the
way to go with this work for humans yeah
probably not